xavier moreau et les directeurs de
straten
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors on va tout d'abord
revenir sur le dernier discours de
vladimir poutine s'était il ya quelques
heures à peine sur le climat il affirme
que son pays cherche des solutions pour
moderniser son secteur énergétique et
affiche son objectif de neutralité
carbone à 2060 qu'il avait déjà
d'ailleurs affirmé et c'est d'ailleurs
un pays qui est très bien avancé on peut
le dire un dans la décarbonisation
en fait ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
lanières poutine est en train
d'anticiper les taxations que des pays
que des structures dirons-nous comme
l'union européenne devrait mettre en
place
justement vis-à-vis de ce qui est
produit par par les hydrocarbures donc
pour ça la russie est ce que le petit
neveu obtenir c'est que en fait soit
pris en compte la production globale de
co2 et comme la russie dispose d'atouts
assez considérable comme vous venez de
le dire par exemple le fait que c'est un
pitre le très en avance sur les
technologies de production de
l'électricité par le nucléaire le fait
que la russie et les plus grandes forêts
au monde est bien fait ce que wenger
poutine veut faire accepter par nord
principalement on va dire les le l'union
européenne et les grands pays européens
c'est que c'est justement ça ce rapport
entre la production de
carbone et l'absorption de carbone par
la russie qui le prit en compte en fait
et c'est là dessus que venir poutine
veut jouer c'est ce qu'il veut obtenir
effectivement alors ne désirant de
vladimir poutine un tout à l'heure je le
disais sur le climat un autre hier et
qui a été marqué par ses propos sur les
makes il a d'ailleurs plaidé en faveur
de la reconnaissance des vaccins on sait
que la russie a créé spoutnik v vaccin
reconnu et donc utiliser un par dpi et
mais pas par d'autres et quand on
regarde de plus près quels sont les pays
qui ont reconnu ce footing mais quels
sont ceux qui n'ont pas reconnu on peut
s'interroger est ce vraiment selon vous
une
cision sanitaires d'une décision
politique
non d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y avait le
directeur de l'observatoire franco-russe
avait fait un tweet dans ce sens il ya
quelques semaines en disant qu'après
avoir discuté avec des sénateurs
français donc c'est arnaud dubien que je
cite il était clair que la décision
d'adopter le scout nick v n'est pas une
question sanitaire mais une question
politique et donc effectivement la
russie a été le premier pays à produire
ce vaccin ce sont des technologies déjà
éprouvées donc n'y a pas d'innovation va
dire particulière comme comme la rn
message est qu'on a pu avoir et il est
évident qu'il ya d'une part une raison
politique de ne pas accepter le vaccin
et puis disons le sans doute des lobby
très puissant qui n'ont pas envie de
voir arriver un concurrent sur un marché
qui compte des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliards de dollars de
bénéfices à perspectives alors c'est
bientôt la fin ce g20 dans quelques
heures on n'a pas encore de communiqué
final on connaît plus ou moins la teneur
des sciences de travail alors que
peut-on retenir monsieur assommé
évidemment tournoi beaucoup parlé de la
question des émissions à effet de serre
mais il faut voir que du côté russe il
ya également eu un discours assez assez
important assez intéressant sur
l'inflation sur le fait que les
occidentaux doivent sortir de leurs
habitudes de que dès que ça va mal on
fait tourner la planche à billets parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une inflation
mondiale qui est extrêmement
préoccupante
et que l'on ressent également enrichir
que la russie du point de vue économique
à une gestion de taux de père de famille
est là ce soit l'union européenne que ce
soit les états unis ont fait tourner la
planche à billets et ont créé une espèce
de spirale inflationniste dont on ne
sait pas trop comment on va en sortir et
surtout qui impacte l'énergie également
puisque quand vous imprimer de la
monnaie et bien ça va dans des actifs
qui existent déjà et donc mon avis il
aime bien plus important que le climat
dans l'immédiat c'est cette c'est à la
fois du point de vue purement actuelle
c'est la poussée de l'inflation et le
fait que l'occident doit sortir de cette
habitude de faire tourner la planche à
billets dès que ça va mal il faut
apprendre quand même à voir
pouvoir avoir un budget d état qui
fonctionne et qui soit équilibrée en
fonction de ce qu'on compte pour
consommer et de ce qu'on produit
xavier moreau je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de strates paul merci à vous
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions